[Music]
little do they know it but these six
creatures are each about to experience a
very unusual death one by one they will
fall prey to the remarkable predatory
antics of a carnivorous plant around the
world there are more than 600 plant
species that supplement a regular diet
of sunlight water and soil with insects
microbes or even frogs and rats
scientists believe that carnivorous in
plants evolved separately at least six
times on our planet suggesting that this
flesh munching adaptation holds a major
benefit for plants carnivorous plants
tend to grow in places with highly
acidic soil which is poor in crucial
nutrients like nitrogen phosphorus and
potassium in these hostile conditions
plants that are able to lure trap and
digest prey have an advantage over those
that rely on soil for their nutrients
take this inhospitable fog where pitcher
plants reign supreme drawn to the
pitchers vivid colors and alluring scent
the fly closes in and slurps its nectar
but this pitcher species has an
ingredient called coning in its nectar a
powerful narcotic to insects as the
coning takes effect the fly grows
sluggish stumbles and falls down the
funnel into a pool of liquid at the base
where he drowns enzymes and bacteria in
the liquid slowly break his body down
into microscopic particles the pitcher
plants can consume through its leaves
occasionally larger prey also tumbles
into the fatal funnel of the pitcher
plant
the second victim faces off with the
sticky sundew plant the sundews tiny
leaves are equipped with a viscous
secretion called blue cyllage the ant is
swiftly trapped in this goo as she
struggles enzymes begin to digest her
body special tentacles sense her
movement and curl around her clenching
her in their suffocating grip once she
is 6 years which can happen in under an
hour the tentacles unfurl again to snare
their next victim two down four to go
the next target meets his end
underground in the coils of the
corkscrew plant he enters the roots
through a tiny slip in search of food
but inside he quickly loses his way
through the tangled labyrinth a forest
of curved hairs prevents his escape
guiding him into a central chamber with
flesh digesting enzymes and deadly low
levels of oxygen in the murky depths of
a nearby pond a tadpole unwittingly
swims into the path of the bladderwort
the speediest of all carnivorous plants
she treads on the bladderworts trigger
and in milliseconds a trap door swings
open and sucks her in trapped half in
and half out she struggles to free
herself while the part of her body
inside the plant gets digested over the
next few hours her writhing sets the
trap off repeatedly each time bringing
her
the plant to be digested alive bit by
bit meanwhile this beetle is bewitched
by sweet-smelling nectar the scent draws
him closer and closer until he lands on
the leaves of the world's most infamous
carnivorous plant his landing triggers
tiny hairs on the surface of the leaves
and the jaws of the Venus flytrap
snaps shut around him the spikes
interlock to seal his fate once closed
believes act like an external stomach
that digests the beetles soft tissues
when they open again a few days later
only the dry husk of his exoskeleton
remains the mayfly is the last creature
standing as she approaches the butter
wart plant she heads for the flowers
that wave high above the plants globs of
adhesive goo she alights on the petals
drinks the nectar and takes off
unscathed these long flower stalks keep
certain insects away from the carnivores
traps a way of separating pollinators
from food off the may fly buzzes to live
a long and fruitful life
[Music]
while these carnivorous characters might
seem villainous remember that plants are
always under attack check out this video
to learn how plants defend themselves
from fungi elephants and everything in
between
[Music]